gaming review of the 16-inch m1 max  macbook pro we're going to start off  with rocket league literally no drop  frames let's turn on diablo 3. this is  absolutely mind-blowing now i'm in  starcraft 2. i'm 106 fps right now 100  607 let's get into world of warcraft i  am so impressed with the performance of  this brand theft auto 5 fps it's not  perfect but it's probably around 50 60.  let's do dota 2 we maxed out the  settings this game is insane let's move  on to counter strike go so far this is  good performance guys 69 fps path of  exile no issues solid 60 fps league of  legends everything maxed out no glitches  the witcher 3 wild hunt we are getting  some a little bit of stuttering pretty  decent fps everything looks great let's  go ahead and get into overwatch oh man  this is so  so bad 36  battery life this can legit be a gaming  laptop